première étape chennevier à une
quinzaine de kilomètres au nord de Dijon
540 habitants 408 inscrits l'école de la
commune abrite le bureau de vote ou des
électeurs restent motivés et conscients
du rôle du Conseil départemental c'est
ce que représente nos communautés nos
villages etc c'est ce que nous
représente un peu plus haut au niveau
des administrations donc je pense que
c'est important de les représenter qu'on
soit représenter un peu plus au dessus
7,6% de votants à 10 heures 23% à midi
35% à 14 heures le pourcentage de
votants reste au dessus de la moyenne
nationale et régionale malgré beaucoup
d'interrogations je pense qu'il y a
peut-être un problème de lisibilité de
ce scrutin de manière globale
c'est-à-dire que je pense que avec la
réforme territoriale qui se joue
derrière beaucoup de gens ont eu du mal
à comprendre comment comment aller
s'organiser les départements à l'avenir
et à mon avis ça joue pas en faveur
effectivement d'une grosse mobilisation
à quelques kilomètres de la saucie 101
habitants dans plus de la moitié des
inscrits avaient déjà voté à 16h faisant
grimper à 60% le taux de participation à
votre massif malgré le changement de
chef-lieu de canton ceci passant d'un
canton rural sincène l'abbaye un canton
semi-urbain Fontaine-lès-Dijon côté
cyclisme là rien n'a changé la course 3
Dijon comme chaque année a bien traversé
la commune